sin is not a cultural expression sin is a human
expression are you with me and the cure is
christ if you're buddhist your problem is sin the
solution is christ if you're rich your problem is
sin the solution is christ if you're female or
male your problem is sin the solution is christ
if you're educated or not your problem is sin the
solution is christ when we strip down the gospels
to its essentials we are not nearly as intimidated
as we tend to be by the prospect of going to
this group or that group or that culture i was
talking to i think it was my wife or somebody
and i said in every culture people understand
what a smile means in every culture you smile
you get a favorable response in every culture
if you show respect you get respect back
in every culture a hungry person wants food
in every culture a thirsty person wants water
in every culture someone in a
burning house wants to be rescued
illinois strips it down to the bare bones and
even beyond that when she wrote there are only
two classes in the world today and only two
classes will be recognized in the judgment
those who violate god's law and those who obey
but long before she wrote the holy ghost told us
then peter opened his mouth and said of a
truth i perceive that god is no respecter
of persons but in every nation the greek word
ethnos meaning ethnicity he that feareth god
and worketh righteousness is accepted with
him let me say it again differently if we
would view humanity the way god does a
lot of the suffering we would not have
i don't need to preach two sermons but this
is on my mind the fact that adam's sin did
not mean the world should be as miserable as it
is today yes christ still had to come and die
but the world could have been a much more pleasant
place than it is now had we done certain things
adjusted our thinking to think like god god says
there are two groups obey disobey do what's right
or not those are the two groups he didn't
say white black blue green asian tall short
two obey me disobey if we
follow that divine sociology
all the tribal warfare all the class warfare
all the ethnic cleansing all of that
satanic rubbish would not blight the world
and so we have to see things through god's
eyes not ours through god's eyes who was it uh
brother carr is brother kerr spoke this morning
told us how god sees every person a christ saw
every man every woman as a potential candidate
for the kingdom that was it a potential i was
talking to a in zimbabwe a business person
who came to my hotel room to talk with me
and i told him and his partner when someone walks
into your business do not see a customer first
see a child a potential child of the kingdom of
god the customer side will take care of itself
are you with me do not see a customer first
because if you see a customer right next to
the customer will be a dollar sign or euro sign
whatever sign australia uses see a potential
member of the kingdom of god you see that first
and let god take care of the rest anyway uh do
three little favors for me favor number one
please open this and turn off your phones
several years ago i was preaching in australia
i don't recall what city brisbane melbourne or
what's the other one sydney right here and you
know outside of australia we think australia
has three cities brisbane melbourne and sydney and
that's it nobody ever mentions perth on the other
side of the universe but uh i was in some city
preaching and a lady sat we were in a theater
you know sloping seats the pit where the band
plays and her phone rang and she reached into her
handbag took out the phone answered it conducted
a conversation right under my nose and then when
she finished she put it away and continued
looking at me as though she'd never sinned
so i uh is the most extreme experience i've ever
had with a phone in the presence of a holy god do
you know if you go to a courtroom well in my part
of the world you can't take the phone in there
here as well if you're a man well let me not say
that because there's a man that i don't say all
right you can't drink water in a courtroom
drink it before you come in you will not die
if you don't drink during the trial just drink
it before you come in the courtroom is not a
restaurant you can't massage your wife's neck play
with her hair you can't do that are you with me
but we do it in the presence of god all the time
i see it with these and so when i ask you please
turn your phone off and speaking from god's
perspective god loves reverence you know god
has killed people before for lack of reverence and
he hasn't forgotten how so please turn your phones
off if you can all right favor number two pray
for me while i speak and simply say lord put your
words in that man's mouth i think of the words of
david in second samuel 23 verse 2 where he said
the spirit of the lord spake by me and his word
was in my tongue very precise i only want to speak
god's words if you pray god will answer and you'll
be safe because what i say will be god's words
your mind will be safe because once i say what i
say and it enters your head you can't get it out
let me say it again as you listen to me and what
i say is entering your mind you cannot get it out
and so if you pray what enters your mind will
be the words of god and there's no need to get
those out and favor number three think as you
listen think i've often said and we'll always
say if people would think they would not
do the things they do they wouldn't smoke
if you stopped and really thought what smoking
does to the system people wouldn't drink
they wouldn't date the people they date if
they would stop and think what am i doing
are you with me let us think as we listen to god's
word let's borrow heads and pray father in heaven
thank you for the gift of life we thank
you so much for acts 17 28. in him we live
and move and have our being we acknowledge
you today god as the source of life and the
sustainer and preserver of life and
as we prepare to listen to your word
we ask you first day god remove the static that
interferes with our grasp of signals from heaven
and that static is sin forgive us father grant to
us the spirit of truth jesus said in john 16 13
how be it when he the spirit of truth is come
he will guide you into all truth dear god
instruct your spirit to guide us into truth
or we will surely guide ourselves into error
now father let the angels surround this place
protect us as we worship you be not only with
me but whoever else is making a presentation now
bless that person i pray in jesus name let god's
people say amen and amen our subject behold the
man behold the man john 19 reading from verse 4
we read from the king james version of
the bible john 19 reading from verse 4
and if i don't wait for you to find the books
bear with me because time flies very quickly
then pilate therefore went forth again and
saith unto them behold i bring him forth to
you that you may know that i find no fault in him
verse 5 then came jesus forth wearing what the
crown of thorns and the purple robe and pilate
said unto them what behold the man here he is
here is your jesus here he is pilate presents
jesus to the jews behold the man take a look
at him i find no fault in him now you and i
are looking at the same man i find no fault
you seem to find every fault here he is take a
look at him behold the man but my emphasis today
is behold god now why do i say that for most of my
life and i grew up in a christian home very godly
mother she still is 97 lives in berrien springs
campus of andrews university and prayed all her
life she's lived all her life for her children
and she still does that today at 97 and uh
so from my childhood up i'd always
seen the bible as old and new
god the father in the old jesus in the
new that's how i have seen the bible until
much much later in my more advanced years and
i had time to reflect without the interference
of somebody else's opinions or philosophies
that i realized and of course considerable
insight from the writers of ellen white
and i thank god for that woman's ministry